facts about the World Cup final that
will blow your mind this is the first
World Cup final for both pragnananda and
Carl sent this makes sense for the 18
year old Prague but unusual for Carlson
who was the favorite for the majority of
the past World Cups in which he's
participated at 18 pragnananda is the
youngest World Cup finalist ever in fact
when this year's World Cup started he
was only 17 earlier in the tournament
Magnus got up from his board in the
middle of a game to graciously
congratulate Prague after he beat
Nakamura in addition to defeating
Nakamura the number two seed he also
took out Carolina the number three seed
if Prague can beat Carlson the number
one seed he will be the first person in
World Cup history to beat all three top
seeds fragnananda is the lowest seed at
number 31 to ever reach the final of the
World Cup since starting the tournament
he's been steadily gaining raiding in
his currently ranked number 23 in the
world